[Música]
eu sou um problema
ou pelo menos a acreditar nisso foi o
que fez eu passar por três grandes
fronteiras na minha vida eu vou contar
um pouco de cada uma delas para vocês
aqui hoje quando era criança eu era
muito sensível
eu era muito tímido era criança mais
tímida do colégio ou pelo menos no
começo da infância
o mundo me doía eu me preocupava com o
aquecimento global com a fome no mundo
vocês sabem aquela cena daquele urso
polar magrinho e cima de uma calota
polar quase derretendo toda eu olhava
para aquele tipo de coisa começava a
chorar mundo me doía muito
eu por ser muito sensível gostava de
poesia também eu escrevi a poesia no
colégio
certa vez a partir de um curso e um tema
que escolhi foi a seca no nordeste
eu também cantei em coral durante muito
tempo da minha vida
pelo menos a minha infância numa
universidade super conhecida por nós
aqui é durante esse tempo cantando no
coral que cantava com um grupo de
mulheres
eu tinha uma das vozes mais agudas do
couro eu achava aquilo incrível eu
achava minha voz super poderosa tinha
muito orgulho dela eu achava sensacional
quando a minha voz se juntava com a voz
de outras pessoas das mulheres dos
homens ea gente foi uma coisa só que só
acontecia naquele momento e naquele
momento me sentia parte de algo muito
maior que relacionava pra todo mundo
com o tempo e com a infância a infância
passando eu fui entendendo exatamente o
que era ser uma pessoa ou ser eu
no mundo que havia entrado mais uma
outra escola me foi dito que poesia e
coral não era coisa de homem passando
pela adolescência fui perdendo a minha
voz
ou pelo menos a sua voz que eu
reconhecia como algo tão incrível que eu
tinha tanto orgulho eu fui entendendo o
que era ser homem na sociedade que a
gente vive
eu fui entendendo e fui sentindo essa
frase quadrante muito tempo na minha
cabeça e foi aí que eu conheci o
bullying a exclusão o medo e agressão
física
coisas que só o colégio conseguem
proporcionar para quem é diferente
setenta por cento de todas as crianças
lgbts porque criança assim lgbt também
lésbicas gays transexuais e bissexuais
não é a gente não falamos sobre isso
isso vai mudar setenta por cento das
crianças passam em algum momento no
colégio por algum tipo de agressão
física de bullying algum tipo de
situação vexatória e elas acabam tendo
vergonha delas mesmas e foi isso que eu
senti durante muito tempo da minha vida
senti muita vergonha mas principalmente
eu sentia vergonha que meus pais
sentiram um dia eles descobrissem que eu
era gay
eu sou gay durante muito tempo eu
construí rotas de fuga na minha cabeça
eu tentei entender formas e desculpas
pra se um dia eles descobrissem isso eu
lembro que naquela época alguém me
perguntasse se eu preferiria fugir de
casa o que meus pais descobrirem eu
preferiria fugir de casa
tamanha a vergonha que eu tinha e à pena
de um dia ser uma vergonha dos meus pais
embora o meu pai sempre pessoas
incríveis isso se provou um tempo certo
dia minha mãe entra no quarto sem eu
estar lá e acaba descobrindo o tenho
certeza porque a gente sempre acha que
os pais não sabem né
mas eles sempre sabem tenho certeza que
eu sou gay eu não vou dizer como o que
ela fez com essa informação nos próximos
meses
mudou totalmente o futuro da minha vida
antes de falar comigo ela passou algum
tempo levando isso para a psicoterapeuta
ela foi entender melhor o que era isso
entender melhor como lidar com a
situação e como falar comigo depois
disso onde ela entra no meu quarto e
disse mano
eu preciso conversar contigo e ela me
fala que descobriu que ela sabia eu com
algumas lágrimas nos olhos e com uma
desculpa pô pronta na ponta da língua
ela vem na minha frente e me dá um
abraço e disse tá tudo certo eu te amo
eu sou tua mãe incrível seria se todos
os pais no mundo fizessem isso procurar
essa informação antes de entrar para a
estatística das famílias que exclui os
seus filhos de casa simplesmente por
serem diferentes ou famílias que fazem
os seus filhos serem próprios refugiados
dentro da própria casa e acontece muito
e eu passei pela primeira grande
fronteira da minha vida a aceitação das
pessoas mais importantes pra mim até
então
e foi aí que eu entendi que talvez não
fosse um problema talvez pelo menos duas
pessoas que eu amava eu poderia ser algo
bom e aí entra no mercado de trabalho e
no mercado de trabalho mesmo sabendo
disso mesmo entendendo que a minha
família o meu ponto de apoio e eu tinha
suporte em casa
eu sabia que se eu tivesse sabia que se
eu tivesse sucesso pra eu ter sucesso na
vida eu teria que deixar uma parte de
mim pra trás que mesmo que na minha
família se não fosse um problema no
mundo era no mercado de trabalho era e
foi aí que todos os dias quando eu
entrava pela porta da empresa e deixar
uma parte de mim pra trás e deixar uma
parte do felipe para trás e foi aí que
eu entendi o que era o trabalho pra quem
era diferente
e foi aí que eu também passei por
situações de preconceito no trabalho
aquelas piadas que parece que não ferem
ninguém
aquela necessidade de autoafirmação
constante dos homens para mostrar que
enfim pertencem a um padrão pertencem
àquela situação e que fazem a gente é
diferente sempre pensar em desculpas ou
pensar na forma mais correta de falar
sobre o jogo de futebol do dia passado
eu tinha certeza que se algum dia me
perguntassem sobre o jogo de futebol
eles vão descobrir na hora porque eu não
ia saber da resposta nenhuma e eu lia o
jornal mesmo para conseguir alguma
resposta e por causa disso eu não
preciso nem dizer que eu fui muito
infeliz
durante muito tempo da minha vida
trabalhando e por causa disso também
eu achei que a área que eu trabalhava e
era o problema
talvez se não fosse eles naquilo que
fazer e eu deixei uma carteira assinada
uma carteira de trabalho assinada
um contracheque interessante para alguém
da minha idade e decide dar um passo
para trás seu estagiário em uma empresa
de tecnologia empresa muito diferente do
de onde já trabalhava e foi aí que eu
dei dois passos para frente e um de
empresa e no primeiro ano que eu
trabalhei nessa empresa o primeiro ano
fui convidado a participar de um grupo
de diversidade inclusão lgbt
vocês conseguem entender o que eu senti
com isso a validação de alguém que
achava que era um problema que achava
que era algo errado ser diferente no seu
próprio emprego têm um espaço e nesse
espaço de dizerem que não só não é um
problema como pode ser a solução
diversidade é bom universidade traz
lucro para a empresa mas mais do que
isso é o mais importante as pessoas mais
produtivas mais felizes as pessoas elas
querem estar ali a gente passa a gostar
mas segundas feiras quando a gente
inclui a gente pensa em diversidade
inclusão dentro da empresa
tudo começa a melhorar tem uma pesquisa
que diz que quando se atinge a equidade
de gênero no ambiente de trabalho a
gente consegue ter até maior 48% maior
margem operacional da empresa
diversidade criar espaços
juros totalmente ligado às pessoas
estarem mais felizes e está totalmente
ligado até espaços mais inovadores
foi aí que eu passei pela segunda grande
fronteira da minha vida a validação de
poder ser quem eu sou daquelas oito
horas diárias de trabalho naquele espaço
que a gente sempre acha que uma tarefa
uma tarefa e que a gente só tem que ir
lá para fazer o que nos é pedido e que a
gente acha que a nossa imaginação a
nossa criatividade também não deve
cruzar a fronteira da empresa e ela
precisa a gente tem que estar 100% lá e
foi nesse momento passando por essa
fronteira e passando de achar que era um
problema por ser diferente ao orgulho
disso
entendendo e sentindo isso que eu fui
atrás essa informação eu fui procurar
entender melhor o que estava acontecendo
porque você sabe quando a gente tem
aquela sensação ou a gente experimenta
algo a gente ver um filme ou escuta uma
música que é tão incrível ea gente não
consegue nem dormir antes de fazer todo
mundo ouvir todo mundo ver
era isso que eu sentia que eu sentia
quando eu olhava e pensava em tudo que
eu tinha passado esse processo de
validação eu queria que as pessoas
também passassem por isso que quem
tivesse sentindo algum tipo de
preconceito ou tivesse sentindo
diminuído no seu trabalho pudessem ter
um espaço onde sindsem assim sentisse
orgulho e foi então que foi apresentado
um gráfico
dentro desse estudo que é muito
simbólico para mim porque ele fala me
fala muita coisa que o número de idéias
com relação ao tempo entre grupos
diversos grupos pouco diverso
basicamente se vê na simbologia desse
gráfico e grupos mais diversos com o
tempo criou muito mais idéias problemas
diferentes grupos pouco diverso - idéias
é bem fácil de entender isso quando a
gente tenta comparar por exemplo essa
platéia gente tão ávida por conhecimento
querendo aprender tão diferente mulheres
homens lgbt ou não ea gente compara como
por exemplo nosso governo federal
onde a gente tem pessoas super iguais
querendo resolver o problema de um país
tão plural onde a gente não tem poder
inovação que a gente precisa diversidade
já a inovação em qualquer lugar que a
gente esteja a ser quem se é gerar
resultados para si mesmo
principalmente e foi aí que eu olhei de
novo esse gráfico ele me falou uma
segunda coisa que consegui ver que esses
dois grupos também representa uma coisa
muito importante
a empresa e as do mundo e também eu
fiquei muito interessado naquela parte
principal onde a gente vê que existe uma
diferença de tempo entre a criação de
idéias e o começo da criação de idéias
de um grupo diverso grupo no universo e
foi aí que pesquisa não dei conta da
segunda parte mais importante
relacionada à diversidade e à partir de
uma pesquisa que eu conheci de uma
grande empresa tecnologia que foi
descobrir dentro dos seus grupos mais
produtivos seus times mais produtivos
qual é a característica principal desses
times ea característica principal dos
filmes de maior sucesso é a segurança
psicológica e daí tudo faz sentido
porque não adianta ter diversidade no
ambiente de trabalho
se a gente não tiver um espaço seguro
para as pessoas serem elas são a
inclusão a segurança psicológica o
espaço seguro é o que faz a gente
realmente conseguir se expressar é o que
faz a gente realmente consegui assumir
risco e não tem medo de ser julgado e se
a gente errar ser colocado o problema em
cima da nossa diversidade ela mulher
então ela fez aquilo
ele errou porque ele é gay isso acontece
o tempo todo
são espaços com menos preconceito
ambientes mais inclusivos relações mais
horizontais colaboração diversidade
inclusão e foi aí que eu também entende
esse gap entre esses dois grupos
diversas e não diversos e o caminho que
a gente ainda tem pra transformar o
mundo que é tão plural mas tampouco
inclusivo ea potência eo potencial que a
gente tem quando a gente conseguir fazer
e ter um mundo inclusivo de inovação
e tudo mais que o preconceito está aqui
no meio
ela grande fronteira que a gente tem que
passar outra informação importante é que
só por causa do machismo estrutural
a gente perde 12 trilhões de dólares por
ano nos países são desenvolvidas pelo
simples fato das mulheres não
conseguirem chegar ao mercado de
trabalho
pelo simples fato de elas serem
colocadas em situações de emprego não
formal ou simplesmente só dentro de casa
e foi aí que eu me coloquei dentro dessa
realidade o que eu passei pela minha
terceira grande fronteira dos nossos
privilégios e eu entendi que mesmo
parceiro tendo passado por tudo que eu
tinha passado eu era um homem branco se
gênero sejam pressionam trans
eu tenho família e amigos
eu não tenho deficiências físicas
aparentes e por causa disso eu olhei pro
mundo e entende que o meu lugar no mundo
era utilizar tudo o que eu aprendi
reconheceu os privilégios pra partir
disso criar grupos
juntar pessoas mover todo o meu esforço
toda a minha paixão pra realmente criar
um ambiente seguro para todo mundo
para realmente da voz de volta para
pessoas que esqueceram as suas
e aí eu aprendi e redescobrir a minha
própria voz e eu entendi que eu queria
realmente vergonha ea única vergonha que
eu poderia ter 600 em cima dos
privilégios não fizesse nada e eu fiz é
totalmente contrário
por causa disso logo vira líder desse
grupo diversidade lgbt da minha empresa
eu criei outros grupos e liderei grupos
mas principalmente eu criei outros
líderes e juntei pessoas
eu não fiz nada sozinho no mundo a gente
não faz nada sozinho
as grandes coisas são conquistadas
juntas e mais do que isso eu fui
reconhecido mas esse reconhecimento
global
ele não é tão importante quanto o
reconhecimento da história eu quero
trazer para vocês
o reconhecimento de que a diversidade
inclusão é importante o reconhecimento
da nossa própria voz
o reconhecimento que isso não é um
problema que se colorido ser diferente
não é um problema
isso é a solução
o mundo ainda me dói ele ainda cheio de
preconceito mas o preconceito é uma
grande barreira uma grande fronteira que
a gente tem que atravessar ea gente só
atravessa
se nós vamos todos juntos obrigado
[Aplausos]